[Music]
dinner's ready
[Music]
why don't you ask me about hungry I did
you said he'd be hungry by 6:00 6:30 now
I'm not so don't want it now how's work
fine something wrong no fine just asking
me
if you don't wanna have it then just
don't have it you don't ease it
I'm sorry but you've got this thing in
her head about like oh I'm gonna make a
really authentic Italian dinner and it's
just like this absolutely rank rule
that's all dente right all right sorry
I'm sick lovely mmm don't ever
[Music]
right come on
oh god see leave me alone no come on get
dressed we're gonna be late come on not
going what you have to come it's not as
any old dinner as my mum's birthday
she's expecting you to be there no I
don't even like your mom I don't know
why you keep on asking me to go to these
things
you don't have to come I'll tell them
you oh not well and try any Valley and
come back and we'll just watch a film Oh
Sonny
[Music]
stop stop it stop what's wrong I said
stop I'm reading reading a book you
never give me any space
sorry get me to cry to you fine no
pressure no I'm sorry Timmy to explode
like that
I love you
but I am a good read huh look very much
Haslem does Collini Dodger Oh
you